foreign
let's go to Katie in Dayton Ohio what's
up Katie
Hi how are you outstanding how are you
I'm doing all right thanks for taking my
calls of course you got it what's up
well my question is how do I forgive my
husband and somewhat my in-laws for
being really irresponsible with student
debt student loans so I uh got married
about a year and a half ago and during
the student loan pause my husband and I
thought we paid off all of his student
loans we went and applied for a mortgage
recently and found out that he had about
14 000 other loans that he didn't know
about and fourteen thousand other loans
or fourteen thousand dollars in another
loan fourteen thousand dollars of
student loans that we did not know about
okay
um and I know we grew up very separate
like differently I my parents were very
on top of teaching me about finances and
making sure I knew what I was getting
into with college debt and things like
that and his parents were a lot more
hands off
and just to have these ones and not know
about them is kind of beyond what I can
comprehend and so I'm really struggling
with all of them just because it feels
like they were very irresponsible and
now it's holding us back in ways that I
wasn't expecting and I want to forgive
all of them and I guess I'm just looking
for advice on how to do that
I have so many questions that are not
really related to your question so I
won't I won't drag this whole call
underwater because I know I do that
sometimes
um
I will say this I you know I worked in
universities for almost two decades
before I came and joined This Crew and
so
um it's very common for parents to take
out student loans and their children's
name
and then use them for other things so
that may have happened
um it may not even be your
husband that took out a loan he just
forgot about
I'll also say that it's super super
common for people to sign up loans to
quote unquote clean off a balance sheet
without ever looking at the loan amount
so what's happened in your home is
it's frustratingly common very very
common that people just take out loans
to pay their rent and get out of school
and they don't look at that final number
and so for someone like you who is
raised to watch what you owe very very
closely
um
this is it doesn't make any sense just
hear me say on the other side of the of
The Ledger this is way way more common
than than you you're the weirdo in this
one okay yeah
um so let me just ask you this are you
gonna leave them
absolutely not are you done with him
you're just like you know what forget
this dude year and a half in he sucks
I'm on to somebody else are you gonna
leave him
okay
um so here's what I'd recommend you do
all right let me ask you are his parents
bad people
no are they like gonna be terrible uh
like in-laws whenever you have kids and
all that I mean they're gonna be just
the worst
okay
so here's what I would do
um I would go out to like Lowe's or Home
Depot or something okay
and I would buy a cinder block
okay it's gonna be like three bucks or
five bucks or something you may have one
laying around your house somewhere
and I want you to get a piece of masking
tape or duct tape and put it across the
whole cinder block
and I want you to write here terrible
financial decisions by husband and
parents okay
and then I want you to hold that cinder
block for 20 to 30 minutes without
setting it down
okay okay
it's good after about 60 seconds it's
going to become so heavy your hands and
arms will go numb and then after about
four or five minutes it's going to be
unbearable
okay
okay if you make 30 minutes you're
stronger than mine than most okay
I'd prefer you to just carry it around
with you until you just need to set it
down right don't injure yourself
um but continue to set it down and I
want you to take it out in the backyard
and throw it in the backyard all the way
by The Back Fence or if you're in an
apartment I want you to go set it down
somewhere in the woods
and I want you to rip the tape off
and never pick that up again
be done with it here's what you're
choosing every every second you don't
forgive
you're opening your eyes and you're
thinking Hmm
I'm gonna make the next few hours
intentionally miserable
that's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna make my life worse
just cause
it'll feel good
can I tell you what I really think
yeah I think you're mad at yourself
a that you didn't that when y'all were
paying this stuff off you either didn't
pull a credit report or you all didn't
get you didn't look at the numbers right
in the right way right
um or you're mad because you have some
dream of a timeline like we're gonna do
this then we're gonna have a baby we're
gonna get a house and I want this car
and now this has disrupted your timeline
because there's 14 000 more dollars to
pay off right
um unless it just got wiped away maybe
it just got wiped away with the new
stuff right so all that to say is
I think you're often our anger like
you're talking about it's we're mad at
ourselves man
and I'm gonna miss I'm gonna lob that
onto some of this you volunteer you
chose this marriage Katie just be
married right yeah
whenever I struggle with forgiving
I always
let me say it like whenever I struggle
with forgiving something
usually it's because I don't want to let
go of the power I hold over a situation
it's a way for me to Lord over to feel
better about myself
mm-hmm
and I just quite honestly have gotten to
a place in my life where I don't have
that energy anymore
and so I probably am too quick to
forgive because I'm not carrying any
more I'm not giving anybody else real
estate or rent free space in my head in
my body that is I don't have enough
space in there man it's a cloudy dark
messy place anyway right you're about to
say something
I think
I think you're right but I think I'm
also very frustrated uh his response to
finding this out somehow he had two
different accounts one in his dad's name
that he used in one in his name and I'm
not sure how that can happen but it did
and the one in his name stopped coming
out of his bank when they did the pause
in March of 2020 when we were engaged or
not yet engaged and uh then since it
just stopped coming out of the account
and we got married and he switched banks
and he just completely forgot about it
so I guess I'm disappointed that he
could be that irresponsible and then
disappointed that he hasn't shown a lot
of ambition since we found out last week
early last week about this because
you know I've been trying to straighten
out things with his credit and it's a
nightmare of getting this person on the
phone and that Persona phone away and on
hold and if he doesn't get someone in
five minutes he just wants to hang up
and okay listen listen listen I feel
like why is this my problem to clean up
there you go because you're not yes
doing it yes and you know what you've
become in short order you've become his
mom
and I tell him I don't want it to be
like that I know but you tell them you
don't want to neither and I know that
you tell him you don't want it to be
like that and then you go act like it
mm-hmm
quit being his mom
and here's the conversation
when you won't clean up this mess
I'm registering that is you don't care
about our financial safety
you don't care enough about me
well that's a childish response
that's immature
foreign
husband ever and I just suck at
everything and I no I'm not gonna have
that
solve the problem
the problem is we found 14 000 more
dollars he's probably really ashamed and
embarrassed
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can't be his mom Katie
you get to be disappointed you should be
you know what else I think you are
terrified
that you married a guy who thinks so
little of you
that he won't go get the counseling that
he needs
that he won't do the work that he needs
to stand up and stop feeding his shame
with secrets and negative self-talk and
inactivity and inaction
that you've married somebody who's so
undisciplined and unwilling to learn new
things
I think your body's terrified of the
next 65 years is what I think
am I right or wrong I do sometimes feel
like I can't trust him to lead our
family and man that he wants to be and
that I want him to be yes have you said
that to him
yes okay
your next step my sister is
to go see somebody
your marriage is in more trouble than
you think it is
because here's what happens next
shame as the great brene Brown says
shame eats secrets for breakfast
the engagements between you two when you
say hey have you dealt with your mess
that you brought to this marriage that's
now our mess have you made that call
Will it call for five minutes and adjust
it and you say am I not worth five more
minutes of your time
and then he shuts down
and then that leads to a culture
of secrecy where he just doesn't tell
you stuff
and that leads to more video games and
more time online and more Netflix and
more pornography and more now we're down
the road am I on the right track
yeah and then not not pornography I'll
say that that you know of Katie that you
know of it's like 90 something percent
of men and then you
have to create another world where you
can exist where bills actually get paid
in the real world where people have
difficult conversations with other
people
and that is the breeding ground for
resentment
when you wake up and you think I'm gonna
do this just because it's going to annoy
him
or he wakes up and says she's already
created her own world what does she even
care I'm just gonna do this because she
didn't care about me
and that's resentment
and y'all are heading there faster than
you know
and so the beautiful thing is you're
brilliant I can tell
foreign
I think he can get there with some
coaching
and with some compassion and some love
he also was probably gonna need a kick
in the booty or two okay
um not literally don't actually kick him
but do what
you need a marriage counselor ASAP
okay okay he will probably end up in his
Zone he's probably got some stuff from
home
if I'm a betting man
I would probably bet that Dad may have
used some of that money he may have
taken out a loan of his own in some
shape form or fashion
it's very very common that that happens
or some sort of Parent PLUS Loan
situation where Mom and Dad take out a
loan that is supposed to go to tuition
who knows what who knows
all that said
carrying around the anger about the past
decisions that they made is a waste of
your energy
what you need to be invested in is
saying okay these things happened and
these character traits have emerged you
Katie are becoming somebody you don't
want to be you don't want to be your
husband's Mom right nobody wants to have
sex with their son that's gross it's
weird right and nobody wants to make out
with their mother right I don't want
this in my home
you are also becoming distrustful which
means you're going to start keeping
things to yourself or just doing things
on your own or talking to people at work
maybe even that guy who's hilarious and
he thinks you're pretty
you are becoming somebody you don't want
to be and you are seeing traits in him
that you don't want to be attached to
yet you said for better or worse so here
we are
and so we're going to go to marriage
counselor and we're going to learn new
ways of interacting with one another and
with ourselves and we're going to do
this a year and a half in you could end
up way decades ahead of most of the
couples in your life if y'all go do the
hard work right now
okay
okay he's gonna have to learn to not
shut down every time somebody calls us
calls us on him on the carpet he's going
to have to learn to do hard things
you're going to have to learn to hold
your boundaries and not be responsible
for how everybody else feels because
you've been a peacemaker most of your
life
okay
okay think of these not as Character
defects think of these as new skills
that you all have to learn because
neither of y'all have ever been married
before right
so we're learning new things moving
forward
what I will tell you as you're learning
new things and you're taking off running
in a New Direction carry as few bricks
with you as possible
set down the old crap man
your parents weren't perfect his weren't
either guaranteed
often they were less than perfect cool
I'm gonna own it they were I'm not
carrying their stuff anymore I got
enough of my own to carry
and the lighter the load is when you'll
take off into the woods carving a brand
new path together
um the easier that trip will be and by
the way the Trip's not easy
and let me let's go ahead and answer
this because this is going to come up on
the YouTube comments Katie if he says
I'm not going to marriage counseling
with you I refuse to go I don't need to
go
you can't make him
I'll be heartbroken for both of you but
you can't make him at that point you've
got to decide I'm gonna go on my own
because you need to learn some new
things because you don't like who you're
becoming
never forget this one important thing
you get to choose
you get to choose
you get to choose